hi this is presh talwalkar in this video  we'll discuss a geometric puzzler  consider the following shape which is a  rectangle that has two tabs at the end  the puzzle is can you cut the shape into  two pieces that can be rearranged to  form a rectangle  so you're not allowed to simply cut off  the tabs you have to cut the piece in a  certain way so that the pieces can be  rearranged to form a rectangle  i'm going to pause the video for a  moment  you can think about how you would solve  this  once you're ready you can keep watching  the video  all right here's the solution you need  to cut the shape with the zigzag  once you do that  the original shape will be divided into  two staircase looking shapes and these  can be rearranged into a rectangle  did you solve it  i hope you liked this video please  subscribe to my channel you can support  me on patreon  catch me on my blog minor decisions  on twitter at preshtalwalker  and you can get my books listed on my  website